thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
making this video possible
to support add free educational videos
on the internet go to the link
in the description let's learn more
about nuclear energy shall we
likes like many kids my age i grew up
watching the simpsons
a show that had at its core a nuclear
power plant providing a job for homer
and
power for the town of springfield the
plant was represented as a technological
marvel capable of producing all the
electricity you could ever need
but also as immensely dangerous between
inadequate safety features and the
workers continued incompetence
it felt as if the town was always on the
verge of ecological catastrophe
this feels representative of how many
people out in the real world view
nuclear power
great at producing electricity but at a
cost
in years past opponents of nuclear power
would point to safe
reliable coal and oil and gas power
plants and say they can produce the same
amount of electricity but without the
potential for environmental disaster
yeah about that due in no small parts to
coal and gas-fired power plants humanity
to date has extracted so much carbon
from the ground and put it in the
atmosphere that our climate is changing
at current rates we have just a decade
or so to make sweeping changes to the
global economy
before the accumulated carbon in the
atmosphere influences the climate in
ways that could be
extremely dangerous advocates for
nuclear power say that now is the time
to replace those fossil fuel power
plants with
nuclear ones nuclear being the only
technology we need to
cleanly power an ever more power hungry
world
at the same time though there is an
extensive anti-nuclear movement
with people claiming that solar and wind
and hydroelectric power can accomplish
the same end goal
but without the risk of catastrophe in
this video we're going to take a deep
dive on this debate
which is incredibly complicated it
involves multiple academic disciplines
and i imagine that no matter what i say
i'm about to piss a lot of people off
please understand though that i've tried
to make this video as balanced as
possible i've tried to be as thorough as
i can and speak to as many academics as
possible i would have loved to have
interviewed more of them for this video
but
2020 over the next couple of minutes
though let's try and answer the
following questions
is nuclear power safe is it the best way
to generate our low carbon electricity
how do energy grids work in practice and
lastly
actually the last one will be a secret
i'll tell you that at the end okay so
firstly
is nuclear power a safe way of
generating electricity
yes secondly is nuclear power the best
no okay uh yeah i should say a bit more
than that
when the general public thinks of
nuclear power they also immediately
think of the big disasters
chernobyl fukushima three mile island
and it's undeniable that nuclear power
plants can
go wrong in ways that other power plants
simply can't
but that risk does need to be clarified
you see there are multiple kinds of
nuclear power plant currently in
operation they all work on the same
principle of nuclear fission
splitting large nuclei apart with
neutrons but using slightly different
configurations
the most popular are pressurized water
reactors followed by boiling water
reactors and then you work all the way
down the list to
fast breeder reactors these all work in
slightly different ways and so any risk
associated with a given reactor type
varies for example the reactor that
partially melted down at three mile
island was a pressurized water reactor
and it was a completely different
kind of incident to the meltdown at
chernobyl which was
a high power channel reactor and the way
that those two reactors work is
completely different so most nuclear
plants can't go the way of chernobyl
the commonalities between the risks
associated with each kind of reactor
are leaks of radioactive material to the
environment either spectacularly in the
form of a meltdown
or over long time scales and the need to
safely store the waste
products associated with the nuclear
fission reaction which
are themselves highly radioactive
incidentally the 2014 american godzilla
movie
underrated godzilla isn't actually a
risk of
nuclear power just for the record the
beta and gamma radiation given off by
radioactive materials that come out in
leaks or in nuclear waste
are dangerous to life forms in that they
can for example cause cancer
now how dangerous is this radiation
normally actually not
very in fact where nuclear plants
displace coal-fired power plants they
actually save lives because they emit
less radiation
and emit fewer particulates which can go
on to cause respiratory problems
however when things go wrong they go
very badly wrong
as they did at chernobyl for example
it's very difficult to get an accurate
figure for how many people have died due
to nuclear accidents and i am
not getting into that debate but it is
highly likely that nuclear accidents to
date have led to the premature
deaths of several thousand people all
this being said
considering the overall operational
history record of nuclear power
particularly when comparing it to fossil
fuels
i would contend that it is a safe way to
generate power
when managed responsibly and when done
with modern technology
it's not really what you see on the
simpsons at all now obviously that's a
personal judgment your opinion
may differ but for the rest of this
video i'm not going to talk about the
safety aspect of nuclear power because
frankly
i think there are bigger issues to
discuss in this
debate and lord we're especially
thankful for nuclear power
the cleanest safest energy source there
is
except for solar which is just a pipe
dream right now okay
properly this time secondly is nuclear
power the best way to generate our low
carbon electricity
now in order to have this discussion we
kind of have to introduce a few
definitions a given power source has
lots of different characteristics
associated with it but we can make
sense of the three most important ones
using a tap as an analogy
the single most important characteristic
is the capacity of a power source how
many
watts is associated with it in the
context of a tap the wattage
is the amount of water leaving the tap
per second
now if you were to collect an amount of
water over a given time
you're measuring how much water gets
produced in a given time period
like an hour we'd refer to that in power
generation
as watt hours or more frequently
kilowatt hours or
megawatt hours so your system needs to
produce enough
water but we're also interested in
producing low carbon electricity so that
is
the carbon emissions associated with
each given unit of water each given unit
of
power we express that in the kilograms
of co2 required
to produce an amount of power lastly we
also have the inertia
of a power system this is a little
tricky to understand but you can think
of it in this context as
if i turn the tap on how quickly does
the water start flowing
and how quickly does it stop flowing if
i turn the tap off
a system with a very high inertia would
take a long time to respond to changes
in the input changes
in the tap but a system with very low
inertia the water would start and stop
flowing
immediately i really need to do the
washing now okay
so if you want to generate electricity
you have three broad options you've got
the fossil fuels
coal gas oil you've got nuclear power
and
you've got the loose collection of
technologies known as renewables now if
you want to generate electricity with a
low carbon impact then fossil fuels are
just
out of the question so you're left with
the choice between nuclear and
renewables i've already met all the
different kinds of nuclear plant but
what are renewables i hear you ask we've
got the classics
solar photovoltaics turning sunshine
into electricity
wind turbines stealing power from the
storm
and hydroelectric it's water
going downhill as well as these
technologies you do have other options
like geothermal power
using the heat within the earth to
create steam to drive turbines you've
got
wave power creating electricity from the
motion of the ocean
and you've got concentrated solar
thermal power
basically what you did as a kid to ants
with a magnifying glass just on a
bit of a bigger scale i've divided
renewables into these two groups because
solar wind and hydroelectric power have
been implemented on a large scale
to date whilst the other technologies
mostly have
not so for the remainder of this video
when i'm talking about renewables
really that means solar wind and hydro
but we will come back to some of those
other technologies
if you're designing a future low-carbon
energy grid then you have these two
options renewables and
nuclear but what are their relative
advantages and disadvantages
well let's consider a few key topics and
keep it tally
firstly and most importantly carbon both
renewables and nuclear power have an
incredibly low
carbon cost for each kilowatt hour of
power that gets produced
but it's not quite as simple as just
comparing those two numbers
specifically we need to know the
lifetime emissions associated with each
source of power
so that means accounting for the carbon
emitted by producing electricity
but also the carbon emitted in
constructing the power plant and in the
case of nuclear power
decommissioning on this front renewables
edge ahead but
by small amount according to figures
from the ipcc
first of all wow they're both so much
better than coal
wind has the lowest carbon cost and
solar and nuclear are about the same
but there's a large spread solar costs
have been coming down though as panels
have got more and more efficient
and so you could reasonably expect the
carbon cost of solar to fall even
further in the future as the panels get
even more efficient the higher cost for
nuclear is largely because it is
very carbon intensive to both build and
decommission you use
lots of concrete meaning the nuclear is
low carbon but only when considered on
long time scales so both are fine
options but renewables definitely have
the slightly lower carbon footprint
next capacity is it possible for nuclear
or renewables to provide all the world's
power
absolutely yes currently about 440
nuclear reactors supply around 10 of the
world's electricity and in france it's
actually about 70
of the nation's electricity so yep
nuclear definitely has the potential
capacity
a list of territories currently generate
all their power from
renewables mostly it's got to be said
hydroelectric power
but solar and wind dominate in for
example to german states and plug the
gap in the dry season in uruguay for
example the difference of course
is that nuclear is incredibly space
efficient it generates a vast amount of
power in a tiny
area while to generate the world's
electricity from solar alone
you would need to cover an area roughly
the size of new mexico with solar panels
so both power sources definitely have
the potential capacity
but nuclear definitely does it in a
smaller
space cost per kilowatt hour simple
enough
what is the dollar cost of generating a
kilowatt hour of energy using either of
these sources
again using data from the ipcc wind and
nuclear are basically on level pegging
with solar again being a bit more
expensive now in many instances
while the cost of producing the
electricity from renewables has
plummeted by some 90 percent in the last
20
years the cost to consumers over that
same period has actually
increased that's largely because you
have to build new
infrastructure because current grids
current grids for example aren't
designed for generation to take place in
residential
areas the electricity is supposed to
flow the other way nuclear power on the
other hand utilizes existing
infrastructure
so for as long as you will be needing to
build new infrastructure for renewables
which would probably be the case for the
next
decade or two nuclear is going to be a
little bit cheaper it works out to be
about the same as
wind but let's say that nuclear is a
little bit cheaper next up
stability by their very nature wind and
solar are
variable sources solar panels don't
produce electricity at night time
wind turbines don't do anything useful
when becomed we describe this as the
stability
of the system so how reliably you can
generate
power no matter what
[Music]
nuclear is absolutely the most stable
option of the two
when running normally power generation
is guaranteed
there are ways to provide stability to a
grid based entirely on renewables
notably storage meaning either batteries
or pumped hydroelectric
having reservoirs of two different
heights though there are more esoteric
options like using a fleet of electric
vehicles as your grid storage
but also hybridization hybridization is
using multiple kinds of renewable energy
in the same grid so for example
combining
wind and solar and tidal power when one
source produces an output
another one can take up the slack in
theory
in practice this works on large scales
as it won't be cloudy or completely
still across an entire continent
and so areas enjoying a glut of power
can supply those which have a shortfall
this
does however rely on grid
interconnectors feeding energy from one
grade or subgrid to another
which means yet more infrastructure
expense nuclear
hands down provides greater stability
and lastly
probably most importantly construction
nuclear power plants are
expensive if you want to build one at
the moment you have to have a few
billion dollars the idea being that by
investing lots of money into one
large centralized power source that you
benefit from economies of scale and you
just keep things
simple this is a problem however if you
don't happen to have a few billion
dollars lying around
or if you live somewhere with a very low
population density such as in rural
areas
where the transmission costs the cost of
getting the electricity from the power
plants to the user can be
very high renewable sources could not be
more
different they form a distributed
network with each component contributing
not as much capacity but
being a lot cheaper this means that
renewables are significantly more
appealing in the developing
world where finance is more difficult to
come across but also where population
densities can be very low particularly
in rural areas
it's estimated that there's around 1
billion people in the world who don't
have access to electricity
and the majority of those especially
those in rural areas
will only gain access to electricity
through
renewable micro grids so small numbers
of renewable generators
separate from the main electricity group
it's not all rosy for renewables they
have issues related to the extraction of
rare earth materials like neodymium that
they need for construction
though mining for nuclear fuels i should
point out isn't exactly great
either and i should also point out that
the environmental impact of both
pale in comparison to the impacts of not
decarbonizing our electricity supply but
the major
issue here is time nuclear power plants
take a long
time to build nuclear plants that were
built in 2018 had an
average construction time of nearly nine
years
and compare that to solar and wind which
can be constructed in a matter of months
considering again that we only have
about a decade to cull our emissions
we actually don't have time to plan and
construct a whole new wave of nuclear
power plants
in summary neither technology delivers a
true
knockout punch renewables can be built
maybe slightly cheaper
they can definitely be built a lot
faster and they are the only option for
electrifying much of the developing
world but that comes at a cost in
infrastructure
and in the stability of the system while
hybrid energy networks paired with
lots of storage can provide a certain
amount of stability
the system is inherently variable and
the technology just isn't ready yet
nuclear on the other hand is expensive
to construct
in terms of money time and carbon but
delivers highly stable centralized power
generation
at a low cost so is nuclear the solution
to generating all
our low carbon electricity no definitely
not there are plenty of cases where a
hybrid renewables network makes a lot
more sense
particularly again in the developing
world and plenty of people
would argue that you don't need nuclear
at all
that you could generate all your
electricity with renewables especially
seeing as we have very little time to
decarbonize and perhaps out of safety
concerns
is this possible well as far back as
2012 a study found that the usa could be
reliably powered by between 80 and 90
renewables
while a 2013 report indicated that
australia could be reliably powered by a
hundred
100
renewables and the technology has
evolved significantly since those
studies
the current state of technology
indicates that perhaps
we don't actually need nuclear anywhere
in the grid
however how do energy grids work
in practice what a lot of people are
probably furiously typing into a comment
section
right now is something like baseload i
can't believe
he's not talking about baseload my
disappointment is immeasurable
and my day is ruined give me ready gold
base load is the concept of the minimum
energy required by an electricity grid
at
all times so while demand may vary on
annual
and daily time scales there will always
be a certain minimum amount of
electricity that the grid will
need so base load generation then needs
to be entirely reliable
and it doesn't need to change very much
if at all historically this base load
was provided by
power plants with high inertia such as
coal and also
nuclear the extra stuff needed on top
the variable demand
was then supplied by flexible power
plants such as gas turbines the
flexibility is potentially needed on
minute to minute time scales such as in
the uk when a big tv program
ends and the entire nation wants to boil
the kettle to make some tea
in case you're not from the uk i just
want to be clear that's not a joke
that that's a thing that actually
happens however regardless of what we
might want a future energy grid to
look like that idea is kind of out of
date
because the ground is shifting under our
feet in what's called the renewable
energy transition you know we are moving
to an energy system with the base we
will not need the base load anymore
so we're we're moving to a new energy
system
and this comes with a renewables
especially with the distributed rig
members
this is professor arturos zervos the
president of the renewable energy
network
and someone who has worked in the
renewable energy industry
for more than 30 years i would say all
the way of looking the system with the
base load
and the rest is changing completely we
don't need a base law
we need we need the power we need every
time but
at each moment of the day but is
it's a it's a new way of looking with
and
in that sense what is extremely
important
also is in your system to have
flexible sources what professor zevos is
saying
is that as people continue to add lots
of distributed small
capacity variable sources to an energy
grid
you just can't think in terms of a base
load anymore
but why why would that be i'm not an
expert in energy grid so
i found one and asked her this is dr
ellen webelen a research associate at
ucl
there are times when the base load will
be lower than it was in the past
because we have these generators that
don't get switched off
when demand goes down like local solar
power for example
when you're looking at national demand
you
um can sometimes see negative demand
because of the way
generation has become localized so if
you've got solar panels on your roof and
you're generating more than you're using
you'll have negative demand so this
concept of base load
is quite outdated in the way it doesn't
consider that people would ever have
negative demand so because more and more
distributed renewables are being added
to the grid such as people putting solar
panels on their houses
now instead of having a graph of
required capacity that looks
like this you have one that looks a bit
like
this so if you're trying to meet the
minimum
requirement of this graph at any given
time remember what i
said about those base load generators
they have very high inertia
meaning they're very stable but they
don't change very easily
and that kind of generator just isn't
appropriate for generating the minimum
energy required for the grid
anymore and bear in mind this isn't
anything to do with whether we want to
generate our power in the future from
nuclear or renewables this is
people in the background adding solar
panels to their houses because it's
cheap and
it saves them money in the long run so
many people are now doing that because
the technology is so cheap that it's
actually starting to cause a few
infrastructure problems
so for example in ireland certainly a
few years ago they were having to limit
the amount of renewable power on the
system because
it didn't provide enough inertia and
they wanted to make sure that the system
was going to be reliable and secure
enough
so they were capping the amount of
renewables they would allow
to be on the system even though there
was more wind that could be provided
they said we can't allow this anymore we
haven't tested it enough
instead of base load generators then you
need what professor jesse jenkins
at princeton refers to as firm low
carbon sources of energy these are
sources of energy that are very reliable
you can turn them on
any time of year and they will work but
crucially they have the flexibility to
ramp
up and down as required by the load so
if the old picture of base load plus x
regeneration is now
out of date how do we design a new
future energy grid
well it needs to have three major
characteristics
capacity flexibility and inertia
we're back here at the tap so your
system needs to have the capacity to
supply as much power as you need
that's basically how much water can the
tap produce as we've already seen
renewables and nuclear both easily have
the
capacity to supply our needs however as
demand on the energy grid is going to be
changing on long
and short time scales you need the
flexibility
to change how much capacity your grid
can
offer now renewables can offer fantastic
flexibility because they are lots of
small power sources that you can connect
and disconnect from the grid as
you see fit nuclear by contrast does not
offer very much flexibility at all
historically i'm aware that modern
plants can
load follow to a certain degree this is
what happens in france for example
but generally speaking nuclear
can't offer the flexibility required for
a modern grid on its own but we come
back to
the inertia so inertia is something that
provides
reliability and stability it comes from
when you have big turbines with
large mass that are turning round so
it's much harder to slow them down if
something happens
whereas wind and solar at the moment
don't provide any inertia to the system
so it becomes less
stable basically okay but if flexibility
and inertia are kind of opposites of
each other how can a system
have both flexibility and inertia
well you can have more than one source
of power
a hybrid solution is always going to
have to be the way
because nothing can provide everything
you need without some downsides
so having a mix because they can provide
different services to the system whether
it's being able to switch them off
really quickly
or providing inertia for stability
nuclear renewables offer quite different
things
so having a mix of them can be a good
option if you want to get rid of fossil
fuels
so just to restate what dr webbing said
there nuclear and solar and wind
offer very different things to an energy
grid while they both have the potential
capacity
solar and wind offer fantastic
flexibility while
nuclear offers much greater we've got
more than zero
inertia to the system so why not combine
them and get the best of both worlds
just in terms of the logistics of having
a system that's wholly
renewable is a huge is a huge endeavor
and something the public would have to
be fully on board with in order to
commit the kind of space requirements
to the renewable energy so i don't think
it's
a question of do we want renewables or
nuclear
or fossil fuels there's got to be some
kind of mix and if you want to cut down
on fossil fuels then nuclear is one
option for doing that because it
provides stability
it provides a huge amount of power in a
fairly small location
notice that dr webb said one option
because while nuclear is just an example
of
firm low carbon power arguably the most
important certainly the most feasible to
roll out
given current technology on a large
scale it remains just one
option other ways to generate power year
round without a carbon footprint include
geothermal power and next generation
geothermal tech is really exciting
large reservoir hydroelectric power
though obviously that's very geography
dependent
biomass and even natural gas power
plants with carbon capture and storage
although that one's almost certainly
best avoided
even without using those other sources
of renewable energy
inertia can be provided in a system with
100 renewables
using storage such as batteries or
pumped hydroelectric but
a that technology just isn't feasible
on scale yet and b
well b actually brings me on to my final
question
why do people think they have to choose
between
nuclear and renewables because you don't
let's say that you didn't want to build
any nuclear plants and want to go 100
renewables is that feasible oh
short answer yes with an f long answer
no
with a but i asked dr webb if you could
construct a grid
with 100 renewables and this was her
answer so having worked at national grid
the idea that something could run on 100
maneuverable was kind of
kind of a crazy idea because there isn't
any inertia coming from renewables and
yet when i asked professor xervos
someone with
decades of experience in the energy
industry whether we
needed nuclear energy in our future
energy mix
so do you think there's a place for
nuclear in in the future energy mix or
is it a source that we should leave
behind
i think that is the source of the 20th
century
it just doesn't have any place in the
renewables i don't think that we need it
so what's going on here this is a
behavior that you see on both sides of
the debate nuclear advocates saying you
need nothing but nuclear
no renewables and renewables advocates
saying you only need renewables and
no nuclear analysis by professor jesse
jenkins shows that 100
renewable generation is entirely
technically possible
however as the proportion of renewables
meaning solar and wind in an energy grid
approaches 100
the average cost of electricity at the
dollar cost per kilowatt hour
increases exponentially yet if you allow
for firm
low carbon resources of which nuclear is
arguably the most important
the cost still rises but by nowhere near
as much
and with far less uncertainty so
renewables advocates are entirely
correct to say that you don't
need nuclear but what you're doing by
saying that
is that you want to make your life a
little bit more difficult and by that i
mean
quite a bit more expensive and by the
same token
people who say that you can entirely
power the world with nuclear no
renewables required
have an element of truth to their
argument but
are ignoring the issues of upfront costs
particularly in time
and the issue of flexibility in the
system so why do people continue to make
these purest
arguments when the data and frankly
common sense
indicate that you get the best of both
worlds by combining the two
ways of generating power well i think
these arguments are so popular
for two reasons firstly people like
simple solutions to alcohol the cause of
and solution to all of life's problems
climate change is incredibly complicated
some people refer to it even as a
perfect storm kind of problem because
it's so complex it's so
uniquely not what our brains evolved to
deal with
that any form of simplicity that can be
introduced is seized upon
both by people who are looking for a
solution that they can understand and
read in a reddit headline
and also by the people who are looking
to market
a given solution nuclear power will save
the world
is a much easier sell than nuclear power
will likely form an important method of
electricity generation in conjunction
with renewables where centralized grids
coincide with a low renewables
percentage
secondly though because nuclear power is
a proxy
and this debate on its most fundamental
level isn't about nuclear power versus
renewable
it's consciously or not about how
different
people view the world nature started the
fight for survival and now she wants to
quit because she's losing
well i say hard cheese but nature's not
our enemy
well surely you agree we can do without
her no i don't agree
no and in this video up until now i've
been framing this as renewables versus
nuclear
and i'm pretty sure that everybody
watching this video will have felt a
certain
gut affinity to one solution or the
other i'm going to massively
oversimplify here but you can broadly
divide
people who advocate climate action into
two groups
the first of which says that we should
carry on as we have done for the past
several centuries just with
new technology that stop carbon
emissions the other group
says that we should use this as an
opportunity to restructure how we
interact with energy and how we interact
with the environment
that former group says that we have a
tried and tested way of producing
energy it just unfortunately happens to
have a high carbon footprint that if
left unchecked
will cause disastrous consequences so
apply
technology to fix the problem you
replace coal with nuclear
and we're good to go and we can carry on
as we always have done it
is a tech-centric approach that sees
humans
as separate from superior to nature
by dint of our scientific prowess we
just need to wait for the right
technology to come along and then we can
carry on with business
as usual nuclear power in particular is
seen by this group as the bright
technological hope of the future
especially if we could just
get it to the next generation of nuclear
power to quote naomi klein in this
changes everything
nuclear is a heavy industrial technology
based
on extraction run in a corporatist
manner with long ties to the military
industrial complex
and as renowned psychiatrist and author
robert j lifton has noted
no technology does more to confirm the
notion that man has tamed nature
and the ability to split the atom by
contrast
that second group sees humanity as in
partnership with
if not at the mercy of nature and as
such
argues that we should reconsider how we
generate and use
energy firstly not standing obstinately
tall in the face of nature's processes
but more
bending with the wind and secondly
accepting
that we need to live lifestyles which
require less energy
if we are to live in equilibrium with
nature
moreover instead of continuing with the
current highly centralized method of
generating electricity and large power
plants owned by corporations
this group argues that electricity
generation should be decentralized and
in some cases owned by the public this
transfers capital
and well power away from a small number
of elites and towards the
general public with this transference
acting as a catalyst for broader
social change and what's the best way to
accomplish all of this
well with cheap and easy to install
renewable energy
again oversimplifying but these two
groups are politically on the right and
on the left
respectively and as with all things in
the 21st century how
you the viewer identify politically
almost certainly significantly
influences
where your opinion lies between these
two groups but there will be a large
number of people watching this
who don't identify as particularly
right-wing or particularly left-wing and
yet have a very strong opinion on this
issue probably towards the pro-nuclear
side
if that's you then i'm not going to tell
you why you think that i think
there are lots of reasons why people
like nuclear power
but i will say that i think one of the
biggest reasons that people
are so into the idea of nuclear power is
because
it represents technology specifically i
think the crucial point here is
what naomi klein describes as our
culture's most intoxicating narrative
the belief that technology is going to
save us from the effects of our actions
our faith in techno wizardry persists
embedded inside the superhero narrative
that at the very last minute
our best and brightest are going to save
us from disaster
arguing that we should delay widespread
action on climate change until a
technological fix becomes available
is so intoxicating and so widespread
because well it means that we don't have
to change our lifestyles right now we
don't need to take action
immediately and also because it appeals
to this internalized idea of humans
being special we're all part of this big
story
and will be saved at the last minute
like in all good stories
but also and most importantly i think
it's because it allows the people with
the most
power to retain their control think
about it it's not surprising
that claiming a technological miracle
can be achieved with just a few years
and a few million dollars of funding
from an eco
billionaire is so widely heard from
those same billionaires and the news
media that they own
because people are currently in a
position of power are motivated to
retain
their control and if a technological fix
does become available they are the
people best positioned to
capitalize on it
[Music]
by contrast if the other viewpoint came
to dominance then those people currently
at the top of
wealth mountain would face challenges
and face calls for them to redistribute
their assets
so this stuff really works certainly
does oh well lots of luck
i don't mean to go full bread tube here
and i certainly don't want to give you
the impression that i'm a banner waving
advocate for that latter perspective
it's certainly the way that i lean but i
see it's flaws i'm somewhere in the
middle between the two
what i'm trying to say here is that this
belief in the
supreme power of technology is
misplaced and dangerous we don't have
the time to wait for some technological
superhero to swoop down and save us and
nor do we need such a hero
the technology to fix our problem is
here it is cheap
and it is perfectly feasible to roll out
on scale
it's renewable energy it's wind and
solar that
will need to be where it's appropriate
supported
by nuclear power this debate has become
an
ideological partisan one and it doesn't
need to be
carbon is our common enemy it's the
reason that we're doing all this in the
first place
what i'm trying to say in this video is
that while nuclear has plenty of
positive points
it has been kind of fetishized by its
proponents and equally
demonized by its opponents partly
because it represents a particular world
view that places humanity's command of
technology at its heart
but also because the narrative nuclear
represents very much favors the
interests of people currently in
positions of
power so they have a reason to promote
it however you identify
politically and whatever you make of
this sociological
analysis i implore you consider this
technology on its
merits not how it fits in with your
worldview or your politics
but what it can and can't
do and based on that information and
that information alone
decide on its role in a future low
carbon
power system this video has been
quite a journey and if you came into it
expecting a nice
binary easy to digest conclusion then
surprise to summarize as neatly as i can
is nuclear power the solution to climate
change
no should we forget about nuclear and
just focus on renewable energy also
no is nuclear power a useful
tool to lower our carbon emissions as
part of a future
hybrid energy grid absolutely
yes nuclear power has advantages and
disadvantages that
neatly mesh with renewable sources like
solar and wind
it's certainly a very useful string to
have to our energy bow
but it is neither a silver bullet nor
even the star player
as i said before we have around 10 years
to accelerate the transition to a low
carbon economy and cut our emissions
and with such a tight deadline the heavy
lifting of electricity generation will
need to be done by solar and wind
nuclear just can't be built
quickly enough with modern designs
renewable technologies on the other hand
have advanced significantly in the last
few decades
and are now cheap easy to deploy and
appropriate for
widespread construction they will be the
star
players especially in rural areas the
important thing to stress
is that this needs to happen now
there simply isn't time for any delays
we meaning voters and energy
shareholders and campaigners
around the world need to start removing
fossil fuels from our energy
mix in my opinion the best way of doing
that the fastest cheapest way of doing
that
is using wind and solar on a large scale
but we also need to have other sources
of energy in the mix
to account for the shortcomings of
variable renewables
i hope that this video demonstrated that
nuclear is a really valuable tool
in accomplishing that but it's not a
silver bullet it's not even the only
option
it's just a very good one i also hope it
showed you that this problem is really
complicated
frankly we have bigger issues to deal
with than endlessly debating
renewables versus nuclear and time is
short so let's focus on what is
important
and let's get to work
i was referring to lowering global
carbon emissions but um
i did also need to do this
this next bit of the video is about
putting this debate
in context and the surprising percentage
of energy that has
nothing to do with electricity it's
available as part of the extended cut of
this video
over on nebula nebula is an educational
streaming service that i helped to
create with other creators like tiazu
aliabdal lindsey ellis and
a ton of others and we all share in the
decision making
and the revenue of the site making
content on youtube puts you at the mercy
of the algorithm
and means that a lot of the time i can't
make the content i want to make as i
know it just
won't get views on youtube nebula allows
us to
experiment with new kinds of content
that can add value to the world
aside from adsense revenue for google on
the site there are no
adverts at all this whole section of the
video is replaced with
extra content and we've created whole
new
experimental shows like tom scott's
money and the mega collaboration working
titles
we've partnered up with curiosity stream
the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the internet and worked
out a deal
where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with the link in the description
not only will you get curiosity stream
but you'll also get a nebula
subscription
for free and that's not a trash
subscription
it's free as long as you're a curiosity
stream member and for a limited time
curiosity stream is offering 26 off all
their annual plans
that's less than 15 a year for both
curiosity stream
and nebula and since we've got to stay
inside you may as well
learn about the history of food tonight
or bioluminescence or the latest
dinosaur science
incidentally i know what i'm doing
tonight so if you go to
curiositystream.com forward slash
simon clark link in the description
you'll get both curiosity stream and
nebula for 26
off it's a great way to support this
channel and the work i do
and educational video more broadly for
just 14.79 a year
thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
making this video possible
thank you so much for watching this
video this one has been gestating for
quite some time and i have tried my best
to be as comprehensive as possible in
how i researched and
wrote it however i'm sure there'll be
plenty of people who
think that i have missed something
important in this debate
and so bearing in mind that i may have
cut it
in the interest of time if you think
i've missed something important
then do let me know down in the comments
shout out to the people who kept pushing
me to make
this video hi zeuf i certainly learned a
lot in the research process and
i hope that it has resulted in something
worthwhile
and if you found this video worthwhile
then please do pop it a like
and share it with your friends who you
think may be interested in
this information thank you again for
watching and
i'll see you in the next one do you like
the new set
by the way